welcome to this video I'm playing before
Biff Biff Biff Biff is this this
character from back to the future there
is an amazing rating difference don't
get that too often very little people
online little very few people online
hello maybe they watch the Olympics you
really could recognize in 2012 during
the summer olympics that there were
there was really a big big slump in
online activity people were watching the
the event very very eagerly i think
though winter olympics is a bit
different still p people will watch
short it's not as much as in the summer
ok we have a queen's gambit declined
somewhat somewhat weird setup in many
many ways right ok I've got them I've
got some space advantage and he's
probably going for f5 I will play g4
though if he goes f5 I'll go g4 wait
it's a g5 just turn just a moment ok
let's let's play let's play it simple
just play for a positional edge g-form
he maybe has g5 so I want I didn't
really want to go down
okay now g four da that's a different
animal I'd let's do that he cannot
really take this is murderous and if we
cannot take i've got i have accomplished
something at least I can capture myself
and then maybe play on the G file yeah I
have not captured yet that's of course
useful i can easily care so long and i
probably will that's a very personal ok
let's let's take and get the Knight to
f4 that's a good square
okay prove prevent any any idea of g5
and now castles long and pile up on the
G file yeah well g5 wasn't really a
threat okay but the age for some it's
not not a big loss of tempo anything
quite often you will play g6 anyway so I
have h5 it's not not a problem the old
position is really a matter of this
terrible c8 bishop and the night only
eight is not doing much as well I can't
even we happen to know this is a
position for inform head-on attack
castles Brooke dg1 double on the g file
what I was trying to say is um I can
easily also move the bishop and get the
knight to e5 now you cannot play Bishop
a6 as a five thanks yeah I must be be
cautious so that I don't allow him to
open any lines on b3 I play three on a
three i play be three this is why I
played the Queen away so that b3 is not
coming with the tempo
okay one question is should i go f3 or
not yeah I prevent even 94 it's not
clear that it's necessary but I'd like
to do that I have king d 2 to cover the
e3 porn in case he plays rookie aid
94 is a move that I must be where so
let's say a play h 594 would be
embarrassing so attention came look to
you one maybe I could take f5 maybe I
should have taken that don't know
yeah I'm probably Rookie of seven I
don't know he must cover g7 I guess okay
now i can take at five should i do that
hmm Kim
it's not easy to see how how else to to
make any progress 94 f takes is now
covered the rook is covered and I'm
threatening rookie 5 him or threatening
us may be a bit much intending it's not
like winning yeah he will lose some time
I guess yeah but black chasm has big
trouble him
black4 fits on time yeah it's not not
very nice yeah does this disposition
right of the opening blossom was really
tricky yeah here I was g4 as always in
an interesting possibility I was
irritated a bit by g5 not sure if this
who 95 is a good reply I was only seeing
this this move and I wasn't really sure
about all that maybe this is even ok but
I don't know it was a bit a bit strange
so this is the easy way to go and term
it's just he has so many pawn weaknesses
am but that's it's difficult really for
black takes and then here maybe queen
takes but no this is some no very
one-sided here basically has no counter
play and I think I lost I lost some time
even so it's funny the computer wants to
do something entirely different he wants
it wants to play a 3 this basically
forces that the tail the capture and
then it wants to play against this pawn
yeah that's not bad at all I mean but I
don't want to play on the F and the G
file the the way up later thing is is
also quite good it keeps the the
pressure on and it's a so many types of
transformations are problematic for
black even an endgame let's say I just
play 93 and pick up the poem before and
the end game is completely lost so there
are many scenarios where don't even need
to check mate them just trade some
pieces that's the real problem I haven't
and easy play and in many cases simple
trades even are enough to convert this
advantage to win okay thanks for
watching